We have been a sort of toying with the idea
of changing the David Pakman show opening
theme song on the basis of remixes made from
a voicemail we received. So let me set this
back up for you. We received the following
voicemail a few weeks ago,
so David Pakman show, it's my favorite show.
You do more good dive, you know
the j Barrett
Hi,
Oh [inaudible]
right? So that really will put you in a good
mood if you are not in one every single day
that you hear that. So we took that and we
offered it to the audience and said, if you
want to remix that, submit it to us and we
will consider a theme song change if there
are some really good ones. I played six options
for you on Monday. Voting has been fast and
furious and the results of the poll, our people
want us to keep the existing theme song. 29%
of the audience says do not change the theme
song. 24% of the audience says replace it
with option number four, which I'll play for
you in a second. A option number five, getting
17% of the vote and some of the other options
really not doing well at all. Um, 0% for option
number six, which is sad. Uh, funniest comment
was that option number four, uh, made me consider
dropping some Molly. So we are going to keep
the theme song that we have, but we are going
to use these new options as um, music before
my livestream start on twitch and youtube.
I actually did that earlier this week during
one of my twitch streams. Just a reminder,
the most popular of the remixes was option
number four from three lawn and the chosen
masters. Take a listen to this one.
[inaudible]
yeah.
okay,
so it goes on from there. That was the most
popular of the options. Number two was a r,
I'm sorry, the second most popular. That's
a confusing way to say it. The second most
popular remix was option number five by someone
known to me only as, sorry for Bat English.
Take a listen to that one.
[inaudible]
then you go my favorite, you know my favorite
yo give do work on do you'll know when you're
ready.
Right. So in any case those were the two most
popular but the verdict is we are not changing
the David Pakman show theme song. Some of
the more common complaints where David, anything
that says that you do more good than you know
in your own theme song is extraordinarily
narcissistic and you shouldn't do, that. Didn't
even occur to me because I was having such
a good time with the songs. Another one was
you really shouldn't have lyrics in the opening
theme and another one was listen, if I send
the show to someone and one of those are the
opening theme songs, it's just not going to
seem as credible of a show as with what you
have now and what's funny is when we switched
the theme song to what it is now, it was like
90% disliked 90% of the messages I got about
it where this is terrible, huge mistake.
Your show is going to lose all credibility
and of course the show is like tripled in
size under the current theme song. So I will
go with the audience and I will not change
the theme song, but sometimes I have to make
a call. These are difficult calls to make
because the audience generally is just averse
to change, but sometimes even if the audience
doesn't want to change, I have to make it.
And so far those decisions have worked out
pretty well in the past. But the no change
vote wins. This one, let me know your reaction.
Let me know your level of devastation about
this decision on Twitter. I'm on Twitter at
the pacman. We've got a great program planned
for you today and I'm very glad you're with
us on this Friday